es ist wirklich ein super schaurige
anblick am rotsee im indischen himalaya
liegen hunderte alte skelette die toten
geben forschungsteams weltweit schon
seit längerer zeit große rätsel auf
woher kommen sie und warum mussten diese
vielen menschen dort sterben
nun wurden die alten skelette erstmalig
untersuchte unter anderem mit hilfe von
dna-analysen
die ergebnisse sind verblüffend doch
gleichzeitig geben sie fachleuten nur
noch mehr rätsel auf klicks und tanzen
fiction hier gibt es täglich spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur dann verpasst
er nichts also los geht's mit dem
geheimnis der toten am einsamen see
herzlich willkommen nicht umsonst trägt
der rub kunst see der mehr als 5000
meter über dem meeresspiegel liegt auch
den spitznamen mystery lake oder
skeleton lake im jahr 1942 wurden hier
nämlich am ufer skelette entdeckt und
das nicht zu knapp es handelt sich um
hunderte von toten die forschungsteams
weltweit große rätsel aufgeben dazu der
indische wissenschaftler 33 es gibt
viele unterschiedliche annahmen darüber
wer diese menschen waren was sie zum
rock und sie führte und warum sie hier
starben einer lokalen legende zufolge
handelt es sich um eine pilgergruppe die
der zornigen göttin under die wii zum
opfer gefallen ist oder handelt es sich
vielleicht um soldaten oder um
mitglieder einer expedition die durch
einen schneesturm ums leben kam eine
äußerst mysteriöse sache denn
schließlich liegt der nur 40 meter große
see ja in einem ziemlich entlegenen
gebiet ein internationales
forschungsteam hat sich jetzt
zusammengeschlossen und knochen proben
von mehr als 70 skeletten genauer
untersucht dazu nutzen die fachleute
verschiedene methoden unter anderem dna
analysen die radiokarbon datierung und
isotopen messungen diese biomolekularen
analysen enthüllen
überraschende ergebnisse bei den toten
handelt es sich nicht um verwandte und
es befinden sich etwa gleich viele
frauen und männer darunter
höchstwahrscheinlich handelt es sich
also weder um eng verwandte pilger oder
eine große familie noch um eine
expedition oder eine armee-einheit doch
der bericht zeigt noch ein weiteres
spannendes ergebnis dazu der forscher
komar azami
tanqueray erst durch die sequenzierung
der mitochondrialen dna von 72 skeletten
wurden wir auf deren unterschiedliche
abstimmungen aufmerksam
obwohl viele der individuen
mitochondriale hatlo gruppen besitzen
die typisch für die aktuelle bevölkerung
indiens sind konnten wir dennoch eine
große gruppe mit aplomb gruppen
feststellen
die charakteristische
bevölkerungsgruppen aus westhausen sind
heißt also im klartext die genetik der
skelette zeigt dass die toten nicht nur
aus der näheren umgebung des sees stammt
sondern aus ganz unterschiedlichen
regionen des subkontinents eine
überraschung sogar für das
forschungsteam selbst 14 tote kommen dem
bericht zufolge sogar aus dem
mittelmeerraum das legt die typische den
sieg naturnahe genetisch sind sie mit
den heutigen bewohnern von kreta und
griechenland verband in der kleinen
stichprobe der bisher untersuchten
geräte fand sich sogar ein toter der aus
südostasien stammt auch eine
ernährungsanalyse zeigte dass die toten
vom rub und sie unterschiedliche
kulturelle identitäten aufweisen dazu
die forscherin view china jagd vom
max-planck-institut für
menschheitsgeschichte aus jena
individuen die der gruppe aus indien
angehören hatten eine stark wechselnde
ernährung die in unterschiedlichem maße
auf hirse anbau basierte was in
übereinstimmung mit den genetischen
ergebnissen steht dass sie einer
vielzahl von sozioökonomischen gruppen
aus südasien angehörten
auch zur todesursache konnte die große
analyse einige fragen klären
bakterielle erreger als todesursache
können es beispielsweise nicht gewesen
sein so die detaillierten untersuchungen
ausgeschlossen werden kann auch dass die
toten bei einem einzigen ereignis zur
selben zeit umgekommen sind die
laboranalysen zeigen dass zwischen den
toten aus dem mittelmeerraum und den
toten aus indien rund 1000 jahre liegen
im 17 bis zwanzigsten jahrhundert kam
wohl die gruppe aus dem mittelmeerraum
zu tode
der tod der indischen gruppe passiert
dagegen bereits im siebten bis zehnten
jahrhundert mindestens zwei ereignisse
die unabhängig voneinander vorgefallen
sind müssen also zu den skeletten vom
rotsee geführt haben bezüglich der
indischen toten äußert das autorenteam
in der aktuellen studie eine vermutung
der rub und see liegt zwar an keiner
großen handelsroute aber er ist teil
einer pilgerroute mehr einander d3 lat
wallfahrt die noch heute alle zwölf
jahre stattfindet in temple in der nahen
umgebung wurden in schriften gefunden
die nahelegen dass diese bilder reisen
bereits vor 1200 jahren stattgefunden
haben
bei solch einer wallfahrt könnte
zumindest ein teil der indischen toten
umgekommen sein
ein rätsel dagegen bleibt wie die zweite
gruppe aus dem mittelmeerraum umgekommen
ist unwahrscheinlich dass auch sie
teilnehmer einer egoistischen
reisegruppe gewesen sind dazu heißt es
in der studie
stattdessen sprechen die daten dafür
dass wir hier eine gruppe von nicht
miteinander verwandten männern und
frauen haben die während der zeit der
ottomanen herrschaft im östlichen
mittelmeerraum geboren wurden doch warum
kamen sie an den entlegenen see und wie
kamen sie dort um diese fragen müssen
durch weitere untersuchungen geklärt
werden die analysen zeigen jedenfalls
dass menschen aus der ganzen welt
interesse am rotsee im himalaya hatten
und als besucher zu ihm kam
es bleibt also weiterhin sehr sehr
mysteriös ein mysteriöses ufo an der
sonne oder etwas ähnliches hat neugier
zone entdeckt was ist es anklicken
anschauen und den kanal mit zahlreichen
sehr mysteriösen videos anschauen bis
dann bleibt dran